I'm not sure where to start either with
why you didn't get to buy a New York
magazine or why the Jim Lehrer are
dropped your 8 minute interview it's
your choice
just pick one when was the interview
recorded and why was it dropped as the
week's go fly by I was done about three
weeks ago or maybe it was about four
weeks ago and it was supposed to air
three weeks ago and it was the true
answer is I have no idea why it was it
was dropped but it was really quite
quite weird and we did an author
interview and you know they invite you
on to talk about a book something you
know about to say you know these are
this is what the book says these are my
opinions and and then they got done and
then it was supposed to air within the
next next week and so then they called
me
Terry Smith who did the interview called
me and he said uh he said oh this is
really embarrassing and I have missus I
don't know how to say this he said but
they're gonna drop they're not going to
do the interview because they they said
it they feel the producers of the show
feel it was unbalanced
I said Terry how can i balance myself
and he said I absolutely agree with you
it's completely it's completely
ridiculous and I went to the mat and I
don't know what to say except I'm sorry
so I said well what do you think is
really going on here and he said well
you know it's it's you know we did this
interview and it's about this this book
that I wrote autumn of the moguls which
is about the guys who run the media
business and as it happened the guys
many of the guys who run the media
business are the guys who underwrite PBS
which is an odd thing because this is
it's obviously PBS is supposed to be
independent from big media but actually
actually they're supported by many of
the people who run big media so anyway
so I got into I got into trouble because
I make fun of these guys
named Michael Eisner
head of Disney right Sumner Redstone
head of icon exactly Barry Diller Rupert
Murdoch a guy by the name of Steve
Ratner who's actually a media one of the
pivotal media bankers who's who is the
head of the chairman of wnet the public
station here in the right and an
underwriter of shows on on PBS so you
know and actually it was a funny
interview it was good Terry and I had a
good time time doing it but I think it I
I can only conclude that it just struck
struck a nerve somebody at the Lehrer
show said oh my god you know we're
offending people that it's probably
smart of us not to offend let me read a
quote from les crystal who's the
executive producer of the Jim Lehrer
news our truth of the matter is this is
from I believe Lloyd gross column in The
Washington Post at the time I'm not sure
it was he here maybe maybe he was
already here yeah it was in Daily News
truth of the matter is we made an
editorial decision not to Brust yet
broadcast interview because we didn't
think it was balanced the idea that
anyone outside the NewsHour had anything
to do with this is utterly false well
I'm not sitting outside of this so I
don't really know what happened except
for the fact that as I say what does
that mean to be balanced
I cannot balance myself well I cannot
represent somebody else's point of view
and in fact was not invited on to
represent anyone else's point of view
other than my own what did you say about
these individuals that you think mean
say what exactly it was that you think
offended everybody uh you know I I just
I mean the point my point in this book
that I've that I've recently written is
that these guys who run the media
business are are are outsized
outsize narcissists I suppose it is all
finally I argue about them and this
attitude is what has been responsible
for the for creating essentially five
companies out of thousands of companies
the aggregation of this of this business
the consolidation and it's what's
responsible for what I see as as as
killing the media business these guys
have made it all about them me me me me
and and then on top of it I kind of went
down as I do in the book and as I did on
the show explaining why this is the the
the endgame the last the curtain call
for for these moguls including not least
of all because because they're old they
can't last too much longer in the case
of Michael Eisner that he's ever you
know a good part of his board actually
several people on his board have
recently resigned but they've resigned
because they're trying to get get him
out of there it's just a bad day to be a
mogul and and so you know I I don't
think actually the interesting thing is
I said such horrible things about them I
say this I say this every week and in my
column in New York magazine I said it in
this book so they must have known that I
was going to come on the air and say
this so you know it's an odd thing to to
to be you know to fly down to Washington
to say what they want me to say and then
to be told oh you you said what we
wanted you to say but suddenly it
occurred to somebody that we ought not
to say have you say what in fact you
said go on to the next topic your
attempt to buy New York Magazine with
what other people moguls he says is the
problem in my in my life that that I am
well I can say that these moguls are
have ruined the media business and are
themselves narcissistic tough guys I
have a helpless attraction to them and
in the case of New York magazine
went into business with them and trying
to buy it but the background in ace who
are Mort Zuckerman who owns the Daily
News Harvey Weinstein who runs
Miramax movie studio Nelson Peltz one of
the the the takeover guys of the of the
80s made a fortune on Snapple our yard
mobiles better than the other Mobile's I
am afraid my moguls are probably just
like the other moguls you didn't get the
magazine who did another mogul Bruce
Wasserstein who was another takeover guy
during the 80s now what runs one of the
the big investment banks but near
amazing 407,000 circulation of what
fifty five million dollars yeah
was it worth it you still worked there I
still wear a New York magazine is a
great magazine I mean it is a place that
I love I would say yeah it's worth it
worth every penny of it Michael Wolf's
book is called autumn of the moguls
it's in your book stores our call comes
from Toledo Ohio go ahead please you're
on the air good morning Michael I wanted
to ask you number one I'm sorry that PBS
did that because m'q New York their
report is one that I I really like to
listen to and excuse me it's one that I
really can't tell you know which way
they lean conservative or liberal
whatever but I really wanted to know are
you just say Michael Wolfe it was more
or less spirited out of Baghdad at the
beginning of the war because of your
reporting yes was insane what in the
same it was not Baghdad it was it was
Qatar but yes I was spirited out of
there yes she's not there I was gonna
ask you know I've never I suppose I
there have been others but I've never
seen anybody get as much publicity as
you've gotten over the fact that you
tried for a magazine and didn't win it
were you surprised at how often you find
your picture in the New York Times
absolutely I often thought in the
beginning there was a story about me and
the times took a lot of pictures and I
and so my my theory is that they were
just a Murtagh
saying the the cost of this photographer
but I it's it's interesting because I
mean the magazine New York magazine is a
small magazine of 425 thousand
circulation magazine a regional magazine
at that is not is is not a big title but
there is something about it that it that
it it speaks to people in the media
business and and I think that's why the
coverage was constant I mean virtually
every day there was a major story about
about the purchase of of this magazine
Michael Wolfe lives in Manhattan he has
three children of what age twenty
sixteen and twelve palm girls and a boy
palm beach florida you're on the air
good morning mr. wolf point of
information and not a pejorative comment
of any kind but in mentioning the names
of these many many moguls it sounds like
the vast majority of the names are
Jewish I'm curious if that is so in if
so of Jews being a small percentage of
the overall population do you have any
theories as to a why so many Jews would
be in this particular business and
secondly is there any thing of being
Jewish that would have them feel a
certain way towards driving a certain
income I would come to fuse me well I
mean New York Magazine is I mean I think
the main point here is New York magazine
is in New York and I suppose New York is
and I am NOT the first to observe the
great Jewish city of the world so beyond
that I I can't that beyond that
demographic happenstance I don't I don't
really see any other conspiracy what is
it like almost a third of the Jews in
the United States live in this town
right two billion or so is that because
what's the reason for that is that
because they came here from a you know
years ago and and stayed here or do they
come here because it's a place that is
attractive by I think for all all of the
reasons that that
you know that you create these
demographic blips yeah I mean Jews
originally came here this became and
because they were here it attracted
other Jews and and it has it has become
it's because it's New York its Jerusalem
but there is an in New York magazine
when I was actually in in the in the
Persian Gulf during the war and I spent
a lot of time with the Al Jazeera folk
and because I was covering covering the
media covering the war and the Al
Jazeera people and remember one of one
of the guys said well what exactly is
New York magazine and and I said off
funny you should ask it is the world's
great Jewish magazine Brooklyn you're on
the air hi I'm thanks for taking my call
um I'm just calling because I think that
from my perspective being a Dean
supporter and a liberal that the overall
coverage of the war and the 2004
election is really coming from a
right-wing perspective precisely because
of what he was talking about earlier and
that is the sponsorship or the people
that really are the funders of news
media and of televisions basically are
capitalists in a in the most I guess a
vicious way of to speak about it so
thanks go back over those names Eisner
Murdoch redstone redstone there's
another one all right well I said Diller
all right where are those four names
politically well I'd say the only one
who is who you could very clearly pin
down is Murdoch and and Murdoch who
who's the CEO of News Corp News Corp
owns Fox the Fox News Channel is is to
the right is conservative
and eiszner would III don't be see news
and and redstone would be CBS news right
and from from a political standpoint
these guys are I think almost
exclusively interested in being at the
point of the least amount of controversy
is she right about the way the media is
covering the war and the president's
well I I would put it a different way I
would say that the that that the media
or the big media is interested in
finding the point of conventional wisdom
they don't want to wander too far and I
think that was the issue with with with
the PBS guys it was not a political
issue it's just you know let's not do
anything that makes our lives more
difficult and and if there is a lien I I
would say that everyone in the media
business and especially in the news
media is aware of the success of Fox so
and I think they're saying saying to
themselves how can we get some of that
that success I mean that's the only
thing that they're really interested in
and so that they go in a that has
inclined them in a in a less liberal
direction autumn of the moguls is the
title of the book our guest is Michael
Wolfe is your column on New York
Magazine calm yes the site is called New
York Metro dot-com Garden City Kansas
good morning good morning
this must be Jewish day on c-span where
do you say that caller well I think that
he's sitting across the table from a
Jewish person and I think that I've been
in the motion picture business 35 years
I feel like I know who runs the motion
picture business the media business
that's fine I don't understand why they
wouldn't run your
I'm missing the point here yeah so mine
well let me ask you this since this
Jewish thing has been beat to death what
do you think about the outsourcing of
our jobs in the United States
Carla we're going to let you go thanks
for calling let's go to Clovis New
Mexico you're on the air Clovis yes yes
everyone leaves a gentleman mentioned
his Jewish except Mr Murdoch
mr. Murdoch's wife is Jewish there are
I'm gonna let you go too because this is
not that's not the topic of this
discussion and I know where you're going
with all of us so let's go to San Diego
California go ahead please good morning
good morning mr. wolf thank you for
taking my call I'm a Republican and I
suspect we don't agree on too awful much
however there's one issue and I think
Brian brought it up earlier today and
it's seem it's my rule of thumb and that
you don't ask the question if you don't
want to hear the answer and I would I
see a lot on these news channels is that
I see people ask a question and then cut
somebody off and it's almost like what
they want is they want to make a name
for themselves or they're trying to make
trying to make a person look bad so they
can get an award almost but when you ask
to guest on and you ask a question the
guest should be able to answer the
question and and that's one reason I
watch Washington journal every morning
the other thing I have and I'd like to
have your comment on this I have seen a
big difference since 9/11 I think people
are trying to become more aware of what
the government's doing and and but I
think the government or let me give you
a for instance Dean I think people think
that the people are stupid I'm I'm an
evangelical and I take offense to
somebody saying well Jesus is going on
my on my bus with me on my bus tour now
right after he says I'm I agree with gay
marriage now I happen to be
an equal-opportunity person no one
should be discriminated against in
housing or an employment but gay
marriage is the whole separate issue of
most evangelicals I would have suspect
that are like me they oppose gay
marriage
thank you anything to comment on there
I'm for gay marriage no no I have no no
I have no comment on that in here
self-explanatory December 22nd column in
New York magazine you wrote as puzzling
considering I've always regarded myself
as an impatient with politics centrist
and dedicated no winger why did you feel
compelled to say that in your column
well it was a column about about being
courted by both sides of the spectrum
there's a new liberal radio network and
and I'm talking to them about about
doing some things for them and and I've
become quite friendly with with the Fox
people and Roger Ailes and and we've
been we've been talking about about
doing some stuff in fact I'm filling in
on the Hannity and Colmes show on
I think the 5th of January or Hannity or
combs combs and and so I found I thought
well this is odd this this it shouldn't
be that I can speak with some some
degree of equanimity to to both sides
and and so then I in an effort to
describe where where I fit into this and
I'm pointing out that I have no that I'm
that I try to be I'm as uninterested in
in the extremes in each extreme as as
the other although I then I got a lot of
flack from especially from conservatives
which was how can you call yourself a
centrist and I said well you know I've
spent I spent the last many years trying
to try to make a fortune for myself and
and I've been married for 23 years so
that seems to me to be right right up
the middle
Manhattan you're on with Michael Wolfe
good morning yes happy holidays mr. lamb
and mr. Wolfe
thank you I just want to get to the
point about these certain issues that
are very important
we have spent I would say over a
trillion dollars fighting terrorism and
I think it's a great thing that we have
been able to make a huge dent on it and
I've also noticed how the European Union
in the United States is spending a lot
of money trying to get to Mars
and if we truly want to be a blessed
planet I think we should do we should
work harder to eradicate starvation from
the planet because these problems that
we are facing today which are hidden
between the the view of religion and we
truly are a nation that is under God and
we have to bear the fruits of that and
all this money that's being thrown out
into space when people are starving and
dying of disease I just think it's it's
way off the reality of truly fearing and
loving a living guy Thank You Carl
Michael Wolff is gonna be hunger in
space too we we don't know Michael Wolfe
is a columnist about the media and
that's what we're talking about this
morning I don't I mean we always like to
hear your views however I do want to ask
you do you ever intend to be get off the
media topic and broaden your commentary
well I mean one of the interesting
things and one of the nice things about
about doing the column is that media
becomes the subtext to write about if
not everything an awful lot I mean I do
i I do a lot of political writing and I
think actually actually the real subject
of politics is media when you're right
about politicians their real goal is to
get on television I went to the Persian
Gulf to write about about the war
because because you could certainly see
the war as not incidentally a major
media event so it's it's been a great
it's one of the great windows of all
time transplant yourself for a moment to
Peoria Illinois you live in Peoria
Illinois
and you've never been much beyond there
and you want to educate yourself about
what's going on in the world I mean from
what you know living in the one of the
information capital of the world what
would you suggest to somebody what would
you do if you lived in Fiore to stay in
touch from that point of view to what's
going on well I mean I think I don't
really think the interesting thing at
this at this point it doesn't really
matter where you live you have you have
as much access to information in in
Peoria as I do on the on the Upper East
Side of Manhattan you know and from from
through any number and any number of
technologies through I think you have
you have whatever your your cable
provider or your satellite I'm sure mr.
Murdoch will give you satellite access
in in Peoria to your to your desktop
machine - you know - I mean mean
literally on and on there is no reason
why why you would feel less need feel
less informed there than anywhere else
now whether you do inform yourself I
mean there are only the point is 24
hours in a day and the the difference is
that I get to do this for a living
living in Manhattan on the Upper East
Side
in Peoria you you you may be doing
something else that that for a living
that requires more of your time than
consuming information Emporium
Pennsylvania for Michael Wolfe good
morning good morning I and then my
husband and I are avid Watchers we've
been watching your program since its
inception I have just one quick
challenge for mr. lamb do you suppose
that you could go through one whole
day's program without mentioning
President Clinton me yes I I mean you
know I I get so tired of keeping this is
this this is this is because you don't
like you don't like mr. Clinton
I'm just saying that I would like just
to not hear his name just one home
program if you could go on you know talk
about he's past history really oh I see
what you're getting at yeah well we
don't I mean I've gone for days without
mentioning President Clinton his wife is
a United States Senator and so you're
gonna continue to hear the word Clinton
probably almost every day oh no and
what's more he continues to represent a
a major position in the Democratic Party
I thought she's getting at the fact we
were blaming Bill Clinton for all the
problems today so I mean it depends on
which side is yeah that's what I was
trying to take your order of our
president so that was why she was coming
at it from that point of view center
port New York you're on the air
hello mr. wolf I I want to get a little
explanation of why you think the media
moguls are in demise it would be a very
good thing of course because I think
most of the people I know are pretty
intimidated about being outspoken I'm
wondering if they're the reason and if
so it's two questions are they the
reason and two what do you see as being
the evidence of the demise well let me
take your second question um yeah I mean
other other than the fact that I that I
mean that there has been especially with
the FCC issues before the FCC rather an
out or an outcry about the consolidation
of the media industry over the last in
during the last couple of months and I
think for the first time people are
starting to say hey wait a minute what
has happened to here here there are only
five companies who have monopolized most
of the information in this in this
country and I think for the first time
people are identifying this as a as a as
a major political issue on top of that
there's another interesting thing that
has been been going on and that people
in the media community and in the
business community and this has been
going on for a few years now have looked
at this and said this isn't work
from from a pure business standpoint
there is something really going wrong
here not one of these companies has has
a you know over the course of the past
generation being a good investment
virtually you would matter of fact not
one of them has kept has kept pace with
the sp500 you don't have any core
business books magazines movies radio
that had that stronger now than it was
ten years ago or ten years before that
and then you have audience flight across
the dial so you're basically your
customers are saying we don't like what
you're offering us so I think for all of
for those business reasons and then for
some some some very clear social and
political reasons people are starting to
say hey there is something wrong here
question about the five companies are
Disney Disney News Corp Viacom Vivendi
which has net which is now now GE and I
know I and and yes AOL Time Warner Time
Warner Time Warner I mean yes well we're
on that just for a moment there's a big
story in Vanity Fair this month picture
of Jerry Levin turned a black t-shirt
and jeans for living out on the west
coast with a new girlfriend and gonna
get married he used to be the leader of
Time Warner right he's the one take on
that I know you're right about going
yeah well well it's just I mean Time
Warner I think was was the moment in
which in which it suddenly occurred to
everybody this is that the consolidation
of the media business was not only a
really bad idea but it has had
disastrous consequences how much money
did stockholders losing all that deal
well I the the acquisition of AOL by
Time Warner it actually was the
acquisition of yeah of AOL of of Time
Warner by AOL was probably the the I
think by by by common agreement the
worst business mistake in the history of
business
and some 80 billion dollars was was was
lost on that and but I think it's not I
think people have come to understand
that not as just one bad deal but as
symptomatic of a whole set of bad deals
in other words the the media business at
some point over the last 20 years people
said said we're not in the newspaper
business we're not in the movie business
we're not in a television business we're
in this media thing called the media
business and so we will acquire all of
these these different businesses which
have ultimately very little to do with
one another and then we will run them as
one to some degree that was called
synergy and that is what in the end of
the day profoundly hasn't worked
Michael Wolf's book autumn of the moguls
we go to Fort Wayne Indiana good morning
good morning I just like to ask mr. wolf
that he sits here and I mean he is a
liberal and he have people like Howard
Dean running for president presidency of
the United States he's the one who
signed into law gay marriage in Vermont
and then all of a sudden he says I won't
get to the south and we'll God out of a
closet and you know it's and like the
day that Saddam Hussein was caught and
he'd watch all the media and they you
would have thought their parents died
how depressed I was about that news I
just like you to comment on that maybe
even talk a little bit about the Soros
guy it's been who was who was gentlemen
Clervaux who was depressed about the
news about Saddam Hussein being tell I
mean just across like cable news and
like just the regular news on local
access I mean you would have thought
their parents died they've all just
seemed so depressed it was great I mean
can you tell us anybody by name that you
feel was depressed that Saddam Hussein
was caught oh I think you've all seen
Dean
shed a tear over it I mean you know he
was the one who had the famous interview
with him I mean yeah but you think dan
Rather I have new watching at the moment
you're talking but he was shedding a
tear over the fact that Saddam was
caught no I sure I think he was shedding
a tear because I think it's just about
put the last nail in the coffin for this
year's presidency
I mean ah you know and I liked it
I'd like to have him to talk about this
Soros guys spending all this money to
try to get Bush out of office thank you
um deal with Dan Rather first was he
shedding a tear for the reason that our
caller you mean let me did let's let's
see if we can think of what the caller
was trying to say so he he was saying
that that dan Rather was shedding there
because this man Bush would be reelected
you know I think it's it's preposterous
I mean one of the interesting subtext
about about looking at the media over
the last last couple of years is this is
this issue of a bias or imputed bias
that that the the Conservatives or the
or the the right-wing believes that the
the traditional the traditional the
traditional media I was going to call
the traditional Center but let's not
even associate it with with positions
the traditional media is has an agenda
has a very specific agenda and other
than as I've said an agenda to to try to
avoid controversy and and increase
profits i I think it's it's it's just a
piece of specious logic Michael Wolff
father of two girls and one boy what do
they do they in school I have a daughter
who's a sophomore Wesleyan University
and I have a tenth grader and a sixth
grader are they interested in all on the
kind of work you do
yeah it's it's I think it's hard not to
not to be at the center of this and not
be somewhat interested sometimes they
are absolutely not interested at all and
it's I get the high hand but sometimes
sometimes I get a little interest sure
Norfolk Virginia good morning morning I
am so excited that Michael Wolfe has
written this book and I'm so sorry that
NPR has decided to ignore this and
ignore that interview I mean I'm I place
NPR about the same level that I place
hold on just said it's not NPR it's PBS
it's Jim lairs Newshour they drop the
interview not NPR but it's always from
from these four persons if they're
Jewish or Christian or Muslim or
whatever that's not the point the point
is that someone is speaking out about
the fact that this president has taken
us from the largest surplus to the
largest deficit many of us get a
visceral reaction when we see those
those repeats of that operation flight
suit horrible thing aboard a u.s. naval
warship when that person who is in in
that flight suit never served and has
never attended a funeral of persons that
he is sent to war on a bunch of lives
like he's taken lives of our very best
young men and women I'm the mother of
three children also
and so I am identified with a mr. Wolfe
when he says sometimes they pay
attention to what you do and sometimes
they wish you weren't doing it I'm a
12-year feminist I absolutely believe in
the rights of the common people and we
know that this aren't the rights of
everybody in this country has been
bought and paid for by people that are
in control now after stealing an
election giving all these contracts to
Bexhill all these colors thank you thank
you thank you thank you for calling
would it if the if the ownership was
different would the coverage be
different and if the coverage were
different would the country be different
yes and yes give us some examples of how
that would work I think if the if the
ownership were different or let's say if
there were there were a greater number
of owners I I mean I I think yeah I
think in inevitably if there are a
greater number of owners there would be
a greater difference in the nature of of
coverage in the nature of of of how the
news not only the news was presented but
the general the all of the the the
information the information flow from
movies to books to to radio
I mean radio is one of the interesting
points and it's it's been consolidated
by a company called called Clear Channel
and suddenly there is no local radio
anymore
radio is radio which was which was
really the local medium that even in
some sense more than newspapers over the
past and this was what happened very
quickly it happened after 1996 radio was
was consolidated primarily by this
company Clear Channel and and with the
the economic premise was we can make
more money if we if we centralize it we
don't have these whose fault is that
it's a it is the fault probably
I think of of Congress and at that point
of a Democratic administration there was
a change in the law that that allowed
the consolidation of radio stations and
it happened immediately so so sure I
mean I think I think radio is the great
example you have gone from from
a medium concerned with local issues and
local style and local sensibility to
something else something else that
became extraordinarily homogenized Big
Sandy Texas from Michael Wolfe of New
York Magazine good morning good morning
Bryan and Michael first of all that just
a little jab at that last caller for
Liberal Democrats to whine about the
deficit is just hilarious after the last
50 years of the Great Society and all
the social spending dumped down the
drain Michael you have presented
yourself this morning as a centrist and
believe that you don't really you know
you're in the middle yet but in like in
Bernard Goldberg's book he gives you a
little test here on the issues like
abortion affirmative action gun control
gay marriage school choice tort reform
the living Constitution taxes and I
would say the war in Iraq or the war on
terror I feel sure that you would come
down on the left side of every one of
those issues maybe I'm wrong yeah but
that's but well um I think that's
probably the problem I mean anybody if
you invent the test then you get to
graded also I obviously would invent
another kind of another kind of of test
- as I was saying saying before I mean
I'm an extraordinarily an extraordinary
believer in American entrepreneurial ISM
having started many businesses and
failed at quite a few of them and you
know and I also have I as I said I've
been married for 23 years it's hard to
be I mean it's hard to think of anything
that defines one more in the center then
having been married for a very long time
I think it suggests a temperament that a
temperament
of a large amount of tolerance and and
perhaps an avoidance of of risk a need
for security
hail Michigan you're on the air good
morning mr. ramen mr. Worf I was calling
in reference to liberalism conservatism
about salmon I noticed on your show mr.
wolf was making a joke about food and
outer space no one to know about this
New York culture so what is its role in
helping people eat if it's a joke or is
that a part of liberalism was watching a
show
rich girls and they're laughing about
people starving in Ethiopia you know but
they want to help so if you can just
give me some information since New York
is our lead center there what New
Yorkers really feel about people
starving and leaving jobs to feed their
children and eating this is a hard
question I think that I think we people
in New York feel the same about
starvation as as you do in where are you
hail Michigan hail Michigan what why do
you think that we feel if she's not
there I don't know what do you what do
you think of what's the real meaning of
this of this question
I suspect listening to her approach is
that the New Yorkers have a cynical
attitude toward the rest of the world
and they're making fun of other parts of
the world where they're starving and she
wants to understand why III think that
there isn't a sense and it's not an
inaccurate sense that that people in New
York make fun of the rest of the world
now the issue is that we have a
different kind of sense of humor a
better sense of humor
let me ask you in that in that regard is
it a good idea then if that's the way
New Yorkers feel about that they
communications head of the headquarters
for the country is in this tent well I
think it's probably why I mean one of
the things I you know I think is that is
that the the the nature of media part of
the nature of media and it's a very
interesting interesting line here is
that people's people say they want to
hear certain things and they want
certain sensibilities respected and they
want certain standards observe and they
want a whole set of those kinds of kinds
of conventions to be honored but if you
do that nobody watches that as a matter
of fact defines what is by nature
uninteresting and boring so you have to
have you have to have people who are
willing to break those conventions is
that well let me ask you in that regard
cuz you've read about in your column
what do you ascribe the success of Bill
O'Reilly to not exactly that I mean I
don't think that this is not a right or
left left issue I think Fox in facts
very clearly broke those conventions and
suddenly people were hearing things that
that they were shocked to hear amused to
hear diverted by and and Fox therefore
became became a hit
throwing the conventional media into
some amount of disarray they kind of
looked at themselves and said oh my god
you know they're doing something that's
more interesting than we're doing and
people can interpret that as right or
left or they can Terp and can interpret
it as interesting not interesting you
guys say today this morning says that
Jesse Ventura show which was only one
night a week you supposed to have a
five-minute week show and they didn't do
that at MSNBC they suspended it
indefinitely what does that say to you
well it actually means if somebody on
cable if you're one night a week
you don't really exist so that was
already in some sense in some sense they
are they already wrote it off by not
going to five days a week and and and
it's it's it's hard to say it's hard
this judge on just one day a week that
means you can't you can't find a stride
you can't you're not you're not really
you're not really in the game Houston
thanks for waiting you're on with
Michael Wolf of New York Magazine
morning Brian great program as always
and good morning mr. wolf come on hi I
wanted to just ask you you mentioned the
right wing perceiving the media
generally is being liberal or biased in
any way in bernard goldberg book and i
that last gentleman kind of saw month
under he describes it as not really that
the right be the media is liberal or
left-wing and able sent but that they
are biased against conservatives that
for one example that if you're pro-life
dan Rather refers to you as
anti-abortion if you're pro-choice well
you you must be a very common sense even
even minded level-headed guy because
you're pro-choice you're you're
ambivalent you'll look at all sides of
the issue and balance it and let the
person make them of course you know
pro-choice what it means it means
anti-abortion generally speaking and why
is it that for example dan Rather would
say anti-abortion people when in fact
they might be pro-life why not you call
from david question caller let me ask
you a question about bias why why is it
that say rush limbaugh who is supposedly
has an audience of twenty million a week
over the top rate of the week is heard
over a regulated radio station can be
biased from a point of view but Dan
Rather's supposed to be unbiased well I
think I think the answer is lies within
the question Rush Limbaugh announces and
declares where he stands on the issues
and he backs up his arguments with with
quotations and information and and
factual arguments and reasoned arguments
dan Rather his claim is unbiased
unbiased unfiltered and getting the
truth from him is balanced all the way
when in fact within his comments one can
see that whether where the emphasis is
placed whether or not there's a
follow-up question I think that's where
Dan Rather's bias comes in is the
emphasis on where his questions are to
whom he's asking the tough questions and
the tough follow-up questions can I can
I do this sure I think there that there
are two Boynton points here I mean
there's the the the Goldberg analysis or
the Goldberg type analysis which is
which is flawed I mean it really relies
on these this kind of textual sense of
of he said this why did he say this then
why did he call so and so this why did
he use this language which is which is
actually I mean if you spend any time
with this you find out oh that's that's
wrong and it says they they do this this
is the kind of LexisNexis search the
LexisNexis analysis you do this search
through through through the the
transcripts and you can do you can do
the other kind of search and mount the
other kind of case so I I mean yeah at
the end of the day I think I think you
could I could argue bernard goldberg
certainly to to a draw but having said
that then let me also on the other side
say yeah of course it's there's there's
a bias why wouldn't there there be a
bias how do you say utter any sentence
or paragraph without a bias but let's
look at the nature the nature of this
what you try to do in the in the media
business is is is find the bias find the
center of your audience everybody has a
different audience we're not we're not
talking about about a universal
spokesman to
to the world or the nation at large so I
I think in each of in each of these
cases everybody there is trying to
reflect the the sensibility and let's
not really call it the politics is
trying to reflect the the sensibility of
of the people who regularly tune in to
hear to follow the broadcasts I mean
this is this is the customer base you
try to you try not to offend your
customer base and you try to court your
customer base your book is published by
Harper Business is that and is owned by
Rupert Murdoch it certainly is and you
say in here about him Murdoch was the
Grand Canyon and the people who worked
for him were the National Park guards
and Rangers chatting with the tourists
about the wonders of the National
Monument do you get any feedback from
anybody that you wrote about yes I get
some people some people are furious like
Steve Rattner former New York Times
reporter who then went on to become a
one of the central investment bankers in
this in this business and and I write
about him at some length and and it's
funny because I don't regard it as
especially negative I mean essentially
it says he made he made this enormous
amount of money and he realized every
every goal he must have had for himself
he is unequivocally in every possible
way a success and he has a very big
apartment which I described at some
length
perhaps envious length some some might
say but he is furious and I'm you know
and I try to think why and in the real
reason I think is that is that I make a
little bit of fun of him I'm a it's
it's I do I seem to do this thing which
which puts people in the position of
having to to or puts people in the
position of finding their self-image
challenged and that people react very
like like a stuck pig
Indianapolis good morning good morning
thanks for taking my call I really enjoy
listening to the callers I want to say I
used to be a lot like the last caller I
think he's from Houston where you know
Fox was the greatest thing since ice
milk and it was just wonderful but
eventually I got tired of them telling
me what to think all the time and I
appreciate your guests comments that the
media is averse to controversy I work
with a group that concerned about
veterans issues and of course we
considered Fox News and Rush Limbaugh
our natural allies and we record and
they are efforts to try to get on the
phone and letter-writing campaigns and
they will cut us off or you know they've
got that six second delay and then they
cut you out and we will go online and
discuss that and we were really
frustrated that we if because we were
criticizing the President on Veterans
issues and they would they wouldn't give
us the time of day and so you know it I
find for Fox to have a conservative
agenda because I'm a conservative and so
I appreciate that but I mean to them to
be anything less than praiseful and
almost kind of sink offense toward
President Bush means you're a moderate
or you're a betrayer or you you support
McCain or something you just can't
there's just no room for criticism and I
had no problem with Dan Rather in his
opinions why shouldn't he have his
opinion and why shouldn't he be allowed
to not say or whatever he wants to
declare his opinion or bias to whatever
degree he wants to I mean that's why
should he do that for someone else's to
do that to someone else's satisfaction
thanks door thank you
where did this come from that all media
has to be fair and balanced what would
you
maybe wouldn't have gotten this 150
years ago so where did it come from I
think it came from Fox
no baby happened we stay we've we've
been in the air 25 years in March and
we've talked about the bias for 25 years
um I mean you can try it I don't know I
do think it came from I mean III think
it's been there there is always that
that there has always been that
criticism from from the right or the
left but I think it was it was it was
marginalized criticism Fox took that and
and made it a it made it the cause the
cause of the moment it it de made it
something that defined its own market
position but where did the idea come
from in this country that the media
should be fair and balanced I mean and
it didn't start with Fox I mean we've
talked to it literally talked about it I
mean there there there is this other
tradition that it has been and and let's
let's go to the to the to the tradition
of us journalism which is which which
has existed with the other tradition I
mean a journalism in this country has
always been fraught divisive partisan
all of that kind of thing but then there
has been this this down the middle this
down the middle view and it's partly
from the networks because remember when
the three networks were were originally
when I went on the air there was an
obligation that your news coverage was
going to be first that you were going to
have news coverage even though it didn't
make him any money and that it was going
to be fair and so this became I think
one of the the the the the guiding
principles the and the main shibboleths
of modern media that news was objective
and then of course there is there are
great examples of this to the New York
Times which stands as the as the as the
the main standard of American journalism
and the point was
to be as objective as you possibly are
they objective yeah I think I think too
I again let's say you know objectivity
is is a is a is a is a Grail that that
doesn't really exist but certainly they
go out of their way and their standards
and practices are to be as as to attempt
to be as fair as possible
Michael Wolfe running out of time we go
to Oak Florida good morning good morning
gentlemen
mr. Wolfe I was wanting to ask your
opinion about affirmative action in
corporate America and how it would apply
to the media ask away I I see well I I
don't I would be tempted to ask you to
be a little more specific I can ask for
it I know I mean I know where he's gonna
is that it has the media or have the
media organizations been as aggressive
on affirmative action as they expect
everybody else to be yes I mean I think
that they probably have is that have
they been have they been
I mean affirmative action is a is a you
know
I mean affirmative action is it is it
really a different standard and involves
involves different programs have so is
the question has the media tried to try
to to get representative to become
demographically representative in its in
its ranks it and it and it has to the
extent that it feels from largely from a
public relations standpoint it has to be
but you know do they have any commit
real true commitment to this no I'd say
our on-site producers here in New York
Peter slannen Barry Katz we go to
Washington DC last call of this program
for
like a wolf excuse me yes hi good
morning and Merry Christmas to you I
have a great concern hope you can answer
this question
President Bush and Republican Party seem
like to me they're gonna try to use
religion you know trying to attack Dean
now because what he said about Jesus and
I really feel that they are really
hitting low because you can I mean you
know you believe in what you believe in
and just to say try to use God and Jesus
to attack someone you don't have to
profess what you believe is what your
deeds are and another thing I like to
know who gave the South the authority to
have a lock on religion I don't
understand I never could understand that
and now I hear all the time about
American is supposed to be a Christian
nation well how can you how can
Americans claim to be a Christian nation
we had slavery and also the Indians are
still trying to get their money go ahead
III think religion has become the great
subtext of American politics with
consequences that we have we have yet to
know it's a it's a very interesting and
extremely dangerous course that we are
on autumn of the Moghuls is the title of
the book by our guest Michael Wolfe you
can also find his column on New York
Metro com.com where a New York magazine
has its website and we thank you very
much for joining us thank you for as
always on January the 5th on Hannity and
Colmes oh you got it you're there for
the week or just for the day just the
day thank you very much thanks and for
our audience have a nice weekend